hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to safari showdown I know
nothing about this game and that's
pretty much my Roque haha I guess I know
everything about this game now I had no
idea it's like a super epic wagon
adventure
I need that whatever it is blue fire
ball God get off my truck use the
elephant [ __ ] with weird M's on your
face why do you have MS on your face is
that just standing for a mad elephant
face I can't even tell and I can't even
get away from you guys you're just too
strong your elephant douches are just
too strong for me okay so this this game
obviously rode in on the insane of us
and okay well I'm dead so I don't even
know what the hell just happened I shot
a bunch of elephants I did what I said I
needed to do in the last game and kill
all the animals why let's go again why
not come here you elephant douches I'm
gonna blast you fold bullets till you're
pooping lead and also you'll be dead and
they're mostly gonna go into your head
OOP give me the blue fire Oh what is an
end what does it end mean I know what
end me get away from my truck you're
such a bunch of butchers Oh big white
elven ah is that a silver relevant oh
wait are the blues female because they
don't have tusks and then are the white
males because I do have tusks and
they're bigger and fatter and lazier and
stupider huh men are dumb am i right
ladies
high five if you agree oh wait a minute
what is whoa what do I have now it's
awesome and why is the why is the
soundtrack so happy and go-lucky okay
let me try to analyze this game for what
it really is this is art in its most
pure form this is pure ecstasy in terms
of Eggman peccable game design
exceptional Ryo my god what's happen
okay
exceptional realism the the drive of the
story is you're trying to escape the
stampede of elephants that are trying to
oh this is not gonna go well do I have a
bomb do I have a bomb any soda bomb
oh okay bye everybody note to self once
you have the D don't ever go away from
the D because D is obviously the best
let's go again you of its sons of
[ __ ] yeah now gonna get this truck
you're not gonna come into it hear me
your bar don't you boo me
suck my flames give me I'm not an
elephant free wish you two made with why
do some days why are you you what hell
are you get oh yeah yeah get out of here
okay all right cool
that's cool I like this I got the D I
got the D that's a green one I got the D
whatever the D is it's the best
everybody loves the D these elephants
don't love the D and maybe they love it
so much they're exploding with joy
I love ours our bodies to start
occurring off into the distance that's a
real elegant feature of this game well
I'm just gonna turn out to live oh it
ran out no I need the D no give me the
day I can't beat off these elephants if
I don't have the D ah goddamn it
this games hard yeah I gotta imagine
this would be a good i phone game give
me that uh and it's just as good and
means nothing why do I have n what does
anybody ever what is even my truck why
is even this am I trying to escape after
stealing the and why are you you again I
got in again and it's not gonna do jack
against the elephants
I need the deer to be someone be me
right now please not touch me with your
elephant prehensile noses also known as
a truck give me the D hey Oh D is stands
for dead one more time whoa wizard
elephant okay bye was irrelevant you did
absolutely nothing in life and I commend
you for that hey I have no idea what
this is is they have no idea but it's
kind of Awesome and charming in a way
even though I'm murdering a bunch of
wildlife there's something truly
beautiful about elephants suck my D you
know they are majestic creatures largest
land animals wrote their history says
some say they're smarter than they
really appear talk map
frames [ __ ] I do love the majestic
qualities of elephants and this game is
actually oddly peaceful pastimes I mean
I can imagine a lot of people I am super
dead
I'm the dead as ever oh god here we go
goodbye girl world okay it really gives
you that otherworldly feel that you know
it is very wholesome in the adventuring
what the hell is with the punk gymnastic
elephant why is that there so you get
the cherished feeling of being at home
with the elephants it's like living with
the gorillas but instead Ruthy elephants
why do you get my end and nothing and
you know the passion that comes out of
it and the passion that goes into it and
the incredible way that this game was
made never tell everybody this just
stands head and shoulders above all the
rest
rides uck what is with blond face my
doodle getting over there
incredible in every way game of the year
I'm dead ten out of ten okay so that was
safari showdown I don't know what I
expected out of it but I think I got
exactly what I needed it was a free game
it's a lot of fun try to beat my husk or
links in the description if you want to
play it thank you all so much for
watching I got a whole bunch more games
down in the description below if you
want to keep watching cool stuff thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
that's not my mom wrong with you unleash